I'm just saying I heard though that
Daniel did you just right before the
pandemic did you just say you're like
giving up on video games and do you
think that was maybe poor timing
no I actually gave I gave up video games
a while ago because I cannot do if I do
video games I do nothing else with my
life
like I I not that you know I've done
very little of actual productive value
while being in quarantine but I know I
did all the time and this way I can like
get myself the illusion of being
productive when I you know read a book
for ten seconds the thing that has
really been getting us through this
quarantine has been has been large lego
sets which which take up a lot of time
are very meditative together what's your
large lego set what is that well we've
made Jurassic Park 1 which is very big
you just got a strange of things one
which is half built but is very cool
because it's like it's got two levels to
it it's the normal world and then the
upside down will this built upside down
on top it's very cool we don't know how
we're gonna put it all together yet it
could all fall apart that's amazing I
know but have you um Jane have you found
any like hobbies or anything to keep you
busy right now other than teaching your
child to the third grade I have taken a
buccal a Lee Walter are you serious no
he's been through this I don't know this
like thing I wanted to be able to play I
guess just because it seems easy to
carry around you know it's like a lot
lighter than a heart so I started I've
only take it like three classes because
I as I say I had to get in the swing of
the school thing first the distance
learning and then I got to this so it's
that kind of fun I can't play any songs
yet just a few chords but it has been
it's definitely my quarantine hobby
that's so like you're not talented
enough that's just being rude that's
just being greedy with your tongue
that's so cool that ukulele is so cool
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going